you'll notice I left my red flag up
there on the board because I'm putting a
red flag against this question - this
will mean nothing to most of you or
almost all of you I think the reasonably
red flag on this one is because this
idea of taking a product that's what
this is a long run right and working out
their pieces that I can take out from
each one in order simplify it the whole
is a really useful school when you get
to a topic in extension - and the
integration the talks at the t-score
recurrence relations which have these
multiplications of many many things and
you must work with these long products
and how to simplify them ok so this idea
of how to take this right and get so
many other is valuable let's have a look
you are 30 by 28 by 26 et cetera ok this
is a bit of a weird thing to look at
right because we've looked at things
like this if I gave you 10 by 9 by 8 and
I said please simplify that for me okay
it's like well you could just say well
it's 720 okay but that's not a
meaningful way of simplifying it doesn't
show you many of the patterns that's
there in fact if anything it flattens
out where the name number came from came
from a very logical spot you'd say well
this number it starts like 10 factorial
starts like 10 factorials right but it
doesn't end like that if it stops and
the pot that it's missing the part that
is missing off the end is the 7 6 5 et
cetera
all the way down to 1 so it's missing 7
factorial so to take away the 7
factorial we divide okay now there's a
similar kind of idea happening here
right this kind of looks like 30
factorial but it's missing pieces rather
than missing a whole bit off the end
right it's missing every second term
okay so how do we get it so that it's a
consecutive sequence of numbers and then
I can write a factorial well this is
actually a consecutive sequence of
numbers it's just not consecutive with
everyone it's every two isn't it right
of skipping it's 2 and 2 and then 2 so
if I were to take out a factor of 2 out
of each of these terms
what would this become it
become 15 by 14 by 13 by da da da da
down to one okay so it would become 15
factorial now then that raises the
question if I am going to take out all
of those twos to leave on the 15
factorial behind very convenient based
on the last question we looked at how
many twos do I have to take out and the
answer is well how many terms are there
and the answer is there are fifteen
terms okay because I just said it's
gonna be 15 factorial once I take out
all the twos so there will be 15 - Zack
- take out so rather than write that I
will say to the power 15 that's it
that's as simple as it gets
now I'm gonna use that trick when I come
down to here right look at this thing
you think okay I'm missing terms again
but I'm missing every alternate one just
like that it's just that I'm missing the
other ones you think oh I know what I'll
do I'll divide by something in order to
turn this into some other factorial
which runs into a problem as soon as you
look at the first term which is prime it
doesn't divide by anything not to
mention the fact that even if it did
divide by something you can guarantee it
won't divide by the next things at the
next one will or the next one well the
next one because odd numbers are jerks
whereas even numbers oh that's a
friendly so what are you gonna do with
this thing what are you doing well right
okay so not quite - look at this right
we started thinking this is kind of like
30 factorial isn't it but one with T's
into a little more we saw actually it's
more like this one it's more 15
factorial than 30 factorial
well now that I know what this thing is
I can relate it to this because if I put
this together with this if I multiply
every term in here by every term in here
what would I get
I would get 30 by 29 by 21 or love I
have this scenario right I've got this
sir I've got 30 factorial but I'm
missing all of these guys right every
single one of these
that's it that's all there is to it
sorry use parts you've already worked
out to advance to other parts of it if
you look at parts it's basically just
keep going